OK.
If you are protesting now or if you plan to
protest someday, you should really know your
rights.
What is the law and what is beyond the law
so that you can be prepared to advocate for
yourself and others if you see protesters
rights being violated and so that you can
remain safe.
Now, I know I don't even have to say this,
but of course, if you break the law, including
by damaging property or attacking people,
you are at risk of getting arrested and of
getting the crap kicked out of you.
By the way, the way things seem to be going
with police and nothing in this video is meant
to help people break the law.
The point is to understand the law and understand
what you're legally allowed to do.
So first of all, the core of this is that
the First Amendment of the to the Constitution
of the United States grants you the right
to assemble.
To use your voice to protest, using your voice
includes things like holding signs as well.
It is legal for law enforcement to ban protesters
from certain physical spaces.
For example, if law enforcement says you can't
walk on the highway to protest.
And there's already.
Most states have rules against walking on
the highway anyway.
And you do it.
You can get arrested for that.
If there is a curfew and you ignore it to
protest, you can get arrested.
Where things get tricky is in the gray area
when you have 99 percent of a protest being
peaceful and one percent starts breaking the
law.
The police do have the right to clear the
entire protest.
And you can get arrested even if you weren't
doing anything wrong.
If after police have said it's time to go.
You stick around.
Now, police are not supposed to immediately
start arresting and tear gassing and hitting
people with batons.
If they say protest has to end, they wait
five seconds and they start beating the crap
out of people.
They're supposed to provide a reasonable amount
of time for people to get out of the area.
And if you are, what, clearly walking away,
you also should not be bothered or or attacked
by police.
Now, this is, as you can imagine, dangerous
because these rules can be misused.
Police can incite a couple of people to break
the law, to then justify clearing an entire
protest.
That's a way in which police can misuse these
rules.
But understand that when part of a protest
has gone bad, legally, I'm not saying morally,
legally, police can clear the entire area.
Now, in terms of where you can protest, I
mentioned highways could be off limits.
That would not be considered a limitation
of your First Amendment rights if police say
you can't walk on the highway and do your
protests there.
There are states that require permits.
If you're going to be in the street or sometimes
on the sidewalk, if you're not going to be
moving and you're going to be blocking traffic
now, pedestrian traffic generally, you do
not need permits to protest while walking
along sidewalks or even in streets.
Sometimes if you are not obstructing traffic
depends on the state.
It's very hard to protest on a road without
obstructing traffic.
So the road protests almost always do need
a permit.
Generally speaking, public spaces can be protest
locations that include sidewalks and parks
and the like doesn't mean you can do it without
a permit in some states.
You must know the laws of your state any time
that you block the passage of people or cars
and this includes on sidewalks, you can be
arrested if you refuse to move.
Understand that.
And again, this can be misused by police.
Police will sometimes say you're blocking
pedestrian traffic and then say, and because
of that, it's time to wrap it up.
And then you stay and you get arrested, even
though traffic may not actually have been
blocked.
Police are supposed to provide a reasonable
opportunity to comply, and that includes sufficient
time and a clear, unobstructed exit path.
We had reports from yesterday that protesters
were sort of corralled onto one of the bridges
in between Manhattan and Brooklyn.
I believe the Manhattan Bridge.
And that would be in violation of if you say
it's time to go, you have to provide an unobstructed
exit path and time to exit.
Now, this means that they can't say the party's
over and within 15 seconds start arresting
people.
But it is sometimes misused by police to claim
we issued a dispersal order and they didn't
move.
A quick note about government buildings.
Government buildings can be exceptions there.
There's sort of public buildings in a sense.
That doesn't mean you can necessarily protest
inside, and that varies by state.
Very important.
If you want to show up and record with your
phone or with a camera or whatever, you can
record what is going on in public and you
can record police no matter what they tell
you.
Again, the trick to watch out for is that
if by recording you are impeding police where
you've decided to stand, if you're getting
in the way of what police are doing, they
can argue you are interfering with police,
you're obstructing law enforcement, as you
can imagine.
That can also be misused.
And you can find examples of police saying
that somebody who's really not obstructing
is obstructing by virtue of where they're
standing to record the advice we generally
see is stand on the sidewalk to record if
the altercation is happening on the sidewalk.
Make sure that you're not in the way of police.
Now, in terms of recording, you are also protesting
in a public space, meaning you can be recorded.
Your picture can be taken.
Your face could be published in media without
your consent.
Understand that when you go to a protest,
you're not starting an altercation because
someone's filming you.
But they do film you and then that is you.
Somewhere that is legal because you are out
in public at a protest.
Police do have pretty broad rights to maintain
law and order and uphold local laws.
And this can sometimes be misapplied to filming.
Be aware, police can't tell you that you have
to turn over your phone.
They can't force you to show them stuff on
your phone.
They need a warrant signed by a judge in order
to do that.
Now, if police approach you because you are
recording, certainly remind the police that
recording in a public space is number one,
of course, legal.
And number two does not count as reasonable
suspicion to believe you have committed a
crime.
In other words, if police say they're there
approaching you because you're acting suspiciously
and all you're doing is filming, filming does
not count as reasonable suspicion.
If you do break the law and get arrested.
The normal search and seizure rules would
apply if police tell you you've got to delete
a video from your phone.
That is not a lawful order from police.
And you don't have to do it.
If police want to search your backpack or
your wallet or your fanny pack before or after
an arrest, you're under no obligation to allow
it.
And you can even say, I do not consent to
a search of my property.
Police typically are allowed to pat you down.
In some states, you do have to give police
your name, but you are not required to give
any other information.
Remember, counter protesters that might not
agree with you also have free speech rights.
And police are supposed to treat both protesters
and counter protesters equally, according
to the ACLU.
Police are permitted if they identify antagonistic
groups.
Police are permitted to keep those groups
separated, but they should allow them to be
within sight and sound of each other.
Otherwise, you're not really able to protest.
You're not really able to counter protest.
If you can only do it out of earshot and visible
range of the people you are protesting.
So then a few notes on police interactions.
If police approach you and you want to talk
to you, you don't have to talk to them, but
don't resist.
Of course, it's better not to run away, but
simply ask, am I being detained or am I free
to go?
If they say you were not free to go, you are
able to inquire what is the crime I'm suspected
of having committed.
That has caused you to detain me if you do
get arrested.
You also don't have to say anything.
Again, in some states you do have to state
your name, but in many states you don't.
The degree of cooperation you want to exhibit
is up to you.
Depends on what you've been doing.
Depends on your priorities at any time.
You can ask for a lawyer and they are required
to provide you one.
Now, can you be fired by your employer for
being at a protest even if you didn't do anything
illegal, even if your participation is protected
by the Constitution?
Unfortunately, the Andrew answer is it depends.
It depends on the state you live and work.
It depends on what kind of job you have.
It depends on what kind of agreement you have
in place with your employer.
If you have won, a lot of people don't really
have such agreements and that one is more
complicated and you should really discuss
it with a lawyer or legal aid service.
But there are many circumstances in which
your employer can dismiss you merely for having
participated in a constitutionally protected
protest.
Very important to understand the law and your
rights when it comes to that.
Let me know if I missed anything important.
Make sure you are following me on Twitter
at David Pakman.
And make sure you're subscribed to the daily
audio podcast on iTunes, Stitcher, Spotify
and Google Play or anywhere you prefer to
get your podcasts.
We'll take a quick break and be back after
this.